are we scientifically literate I think
that would be a resounding no overall I
hope that it's getting better and I see
some evidence that it is among the high
school kids that I talked to but you
know we live in a society that
historically has favored the humanities
and the trades over science science is
thought of as being something esoteric
that goes on behind closed doors guys in
white code speaking a secret language it
doesn't affect our everyday lives in
fact science has much more of an effect
on everyday life than any other realm of
human endeavor because the stuff that we
do in the lab ultimately makes its way
out into the marketplace or it changes
people's a notion of who they are and
how they're related to each other
whatever it might be science does have a
very profound effect on human life and
you know the pace of scientific change
is accelerating
you know we're discovering more these
days than we ever have in history
scientific history human history and you
know the pace of change is so high that
even scientists can't keep up with it so
we can't expect the public to know
everything but I think people should be
somewhat literate in science they should
be able to you know tell you something
about the way the universe works about
the way the earth orbits around the Sun
described DNA and actually be able to
define what it is and what it does you
know know what a mutation is know the
basics of Medicine the diseases that you
come down with they're the most people
will come down with and and how they
work so that you can keep on the lookout
for them I mean I think that a certain
basic level of scientific literacy is
simply necessary in the same way that
you know we learn to do addition and
subtraction we can balance our
checkbooks I mean to me these are just
basic everyday things that every citizen
needs to be aware of in part because of
that incredible pace of change in the
moment and the idea that science is
becoming so powerful now that the debate
is really not about can we do this
anymore it's more about should we do
this
should we be making these choices
discovering these things using the
technology and this way or that way
these are broader social questions
they're not simply things that should be
left up to the scientists there's
something every citizen has a stake in
ethically modified foods do we want that
as a society you know there's a lot of
debate and I think there's a lot of
misinformation on both sides some people
who oppose it but don't really
understand it and people who you know
perhaps have a vested interest and think
that it's completely safe but it is a
debate that we need to have as a society
and to have a debate you need to have
some background knowledge to be able to
discuss